[Musique]
je vais me la faire cette soirée vous
voir un anniversaire mais libye la vie
est courte
tu sais carpediem etc des chapelles mon
temps libre ne regarde que moi ce sont
mes choix
[Musique]
bon anniversaire bibiche que j'étais en
train de faire quoi quoi tu vois je me
caty c'est la liberté mais voilà donc
les personnes la bouche se mettre à
table je veux gagner
non ça fait chier c'est carrément
glauque
bon alors tu te décides à me dire ce qui
se passe j'arrête pas de mourir et qu'il
te re vivre toujours la même soirée pas
plus tôt leurs enfants ouais c'est
douloureux
non je vais pas bien j'en viens à me
questionner sur ma santé mentale au
temps passé par l'escalier de secours
sur son escalier de secours mais il faut
que je modifie les prestations non
annonce airbnb si j'avais su pourquoi
ton problème avec les escaliers or une
langue l'histoire qui a impliqué
plusieurs dizaines de morts rex et
plusieurs comme ça jamais tenu si
longtemps ça tant chez lui pique ses
tricks
mais je passe une soirée interminables
et un tantinet rôle ou est ce qu'on sait
déjà rencontré rate faire
tu vas arrêter de te comporter comme une
tare et tu fais quoi là tu veux que
j'appelle mon gars bellevue il sympa cet
hôpital au moins en tout cas c'est celui
qui est le plus proche de chez moi c'est
moi partir je te regarde là en ce moment
guettant la mort h à prendre du lait
tu es de cette graine il cherchait son
chemin vers le soleil est-ce que tu as
pourtant encore en toi
on mérite pas d'aller
pas capté qu'on allait mourir je me
rends permanence c'est pas grave
[Musique]
non pas moi